two days ago this broken house was a
home but then Taal volcano erupted and
the ground opened up Tessie watched as
the walls lit apart
sunday is Rita poon Amina in deep organ
in total agony and low melon Nguyen
lindahl then Amanda Nuremberg and Xavier
the program in a crash Jan sorry we
didn't go again Doolittle Lynn Lynn Don
Lamanna punaluu marine Demetria this
volcano has changed thousands of lives
three elderly people who lived here and
now in an evacuation center they have no
money to rebuild it may never be safe to
return here it makes me really sad it's
no better sense
[Music]
for the first time in my life
ash from the volcano now poisons the air
while hundreds of earthquakes buckle the
ground cracks and fissures like this
have been appearing in ground and in
buildings all around the volcano and if
you have a look in you can see just how
deep some of them have become and
experts are saying that this could be a
sign of further unrest within to howl
and a bigger eruption may still be on
the way but many are still ignoring the
warnings coast guards are on alert to
stop residents going back to their homes
on the volcanic island soon we spot a
boat returning
horses are onboard a vital source of
income the men couldn't afford to leave
the behind and soon another group
arrived so that's a flat-screen tell me
what else did you go chicken but it's
very dangerous you could die just making
that Journal is it worth it you know for
Minami Denis found his dog trapped when
he returned to the island he managed to
bring him back safely everything else is
gone well I'm kind of worn by and
innamorata sort of idea my Polat nah
mean dude well I don't know Koko Nana
Nana voy para hidden operating point
animal while people here are frantically
trying to get life back to normal until
the danger passes thousands of lives are
on hold they cannot go home they cannot
move on she's on Robins Sky News the
variants